Let's go next to Kate from Denmark, Denmark, one
of my favorite countries. Kate, you're on the air.
Kate from Denmark, please, on
mute yourself, you are on the air,
but you do need to know.
I didn't really know.
I know it's been a while since I've listened to
so because I've been busy, so I'm a little behind.
That's OK. Good news. But I heard that a
new bill is perhaps maybe being passed.
That will be. Making it easier to
rush to show to vote in America.
Have you heard about that one? No, I haven't.
Is this this is a federal bill for what? Automatic
voter registration? I know of states that are
doing this, but I've not heard of the bill.
You're talking about, Kate, something familiar
to it. It was supposed to make it easier also.
What was it there was another thing in the bill,
something like, if you donate a certain amount to
small representatives, it'll be matched up.
So if you donate, I think it was timbal in
dollars, it will be to 17. At least it'll be it
would be easier for small people like Democrats
or black people and such to actually have a
chance instead of just to big representatives,
smaller people like Democrats or black people.
Kate, I've got to tell you, I don't know what
you're talking about, but I will
look into it. I can tell you that.
Yeah, I just heard I'm not sure
if it was something solid, but a
friend of mine mentioned that they
heard it on another news show and.
All right, I will look into that, I will look
into that how are things in Denmark, by the way?
There are currently as well as they can
be, we just had a snowstorm recently.
OK, but if it's Crono Wise, we're still on
lockdown and it looks like it might be extended.
I see. And are you and are you in Copenhagen
or are you elsewhere in the country?
No, I am in the commune called Earth, yes.
Did you say to commune? Yeah, and it's
instead of state, it's called
koruna in Denmark are OK, but it is a commune.
Am I understanding that correctly?
Yeah. Come on come you. And
how is that? Do you like that.
Oh, it's basically like a state
like Denmark is set up in gypping
comes so much it easier to handle some of
farming lands and others more like big cities
like Oklahoma. So they need different things.
Oh, I see. I think we're talking about. So
you're not saying what I understand
as a commune is something else. OK,
I understand. I understand. Yeah. OK, good.
Well, listen, Kate, I appreciate the call. I
hope to get back to Denmark as soon as it's safe.
Yeah, that would be lovely. Have a nice evening.
All right, you too, Kate from
Denmark. Great to hear from her